let's get to a beautiful weekend
everybody but we're going to get some
through some wind before we can get
these temperatures down if it's been a
little too hot for you we were in the
upper 90s near 100 degrees yesterday
starting out in the 70s this morning
some 60s but not too many
nellis 69 aliantes 68 centennial hills
69
it's about everybody else sticking to
the 70s and this is always our coolest
time of day when we get in that first
hour of daylight 70 degrees right now
out at red rock and 50s up there at kyle
canyon we're not really feeling any
winds yet
yesterday we had some breezes in the
afternoon hours
and they did get up over 20 miles an
hour in a few spots we're going to get
those again
up to about 25 miles an hour as we get
through the afternoon but it's kind of
the beginning
of a windy weekend for us 72 right now
in laughlin 70 in boulder city
60's in mesquite 48 in cali any there
are some red flag warnings
across southern utah for today as the
winds will be a little bit blusterier up
there so be careful
elevated fire weather danger for us
really all into
all the way into the weekend and the
national weather service might issue
some
for our areas in southern nevada but
they haven't as of yet thunderstorms are
firing now
from the midwest all the way through the
high plains and those will intensify i'm
afraid
through the day so we're looking at this
is what we call a stationary front it's
a mix of warm and cold front
that's draped over northern nevada it's
got some showers with it but
very limited on moisture and we're not
going to get any of that we're just
going to get the southerly winds being
drawn up ahead of it
and then a stronger area of low pressure
will slide down the west coast
later today into saturday and that's
going to deliver the stronger
gustier winds for saturday so today up
to about 25 miles an hour normal high is
88
we're looking for about 10 degrees above
that again just like yesterday
and then tomorrow the gustier stronger
winds we start to cool just a little bit
into the mid 90s
and then we drop another 10 degrees into
the mid-80s so actually below normal for
sunday
with northerly breezes a slight chance
of some mountain showers
on sunday no rain for the valley but
some mountain showers possible
and then we're kind of up and down next
week between 80's and 90's
more wind on thursday